David Boder: [In English] Spool 152A, Spool 152A. Ilmar A., that seems the name, it can be corrected later. Spool 152A. Boder. These are the short spools from the students of the UNRRA University.
David Boder: Munich, September the 24th, 1946, at the Deutsches Museum in Munich, the UNRRA University for Displaced Persons. The interviewee is Mr. Hilman, [corrects himself] Ilmar A., 23 years old, an Estonian, who is going to give us a half-hour report on his experiences. We are reducing it now to half-hours because the students want to have a cross-section to report.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Ilmar.
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Ich will Ihnen etwas klar sagen. Erzählen Sie mir nicht allgemeine Sachen über die politische Lage oder so. Darüber sind [evtl. „wir informiert“]. Was ich will, Sie sollen zu mir in einer halben Stunde alles nacherzählen, was Ihnen [betont] persönlich und Ihrer Familie passiert ist. Nicht wahr? Nicht die allgemeine Daten oder so was und wenn Sie Sich auch [Satzende unverständlich]. Nicht wahr? Also, ich will folgendes: Wollen Sie mir sagen, wo Sie waren, was Ihnen passiert hat, von der Zeit, dass die Sowjets nach Estland gekommen sind, nicht wahr...
David Boder: ..bis heutigen Tag. Aber Ihnen persönlich. Wo haben Sie gelebt, mit Ihren Eltern. Wo sind Sie gegangen? Was hat Ihnen passiert? Nicht wahr? Also, sprechen Sie hier in der Direktion [Anm.: er meint „Richtung“] des Mikrofons. [Beugen Sie [es] sich runter], kommen Sie näher. Sagen Sie mir nochmal, wo waren Sie und was hat Ihnen passiert, wenn die Sowjets nach Estonien gekommen sind?
Ilmar A.: Wenn die Sowjets in Estonien gekommen, dann war, dann war ich Schüler in der, das war in 1940.
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie dann? In welcher Klasse waren Sie in der Schule?
Ilmar A.: Dann war ich siebzehn Jahre alt. Dann war ich siebzehn Jahre alt. Und ich besuchte die erste Klasse im Gymnasium.
David Boder: Was heißt „erste Klasse“? Die höchste Klasse?
Ilmar A.: „Die erste“ das heißt der, die vierte Klasse, vierte Klasse
David Boder: . . . der Volks-
Ilmar A.: der Volks-, äh, der Mittelschule.
David Boder: Ja. Die vierte Klasse der Mittelschule. Das war also nach dem Pro-Gymnasium?
Ilmar A.: Das war nach dem Pro-Gymnasium.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, und in welcher Stadt waren Sie?
Ilmar A.: Das war in Tartu.
David Boder: In Dorpat [Anm.: dt. Name von Tartu]?
Ilmar A.: In Dorpat.
David Boder: Aha, das war die berühmte Jurjev Universität.
Ilmar A.: Jurjev Universität.
David Boder: Ja. Und wer waren Ihre Eltern, Ilman?Boder spricht den Namen oft Ilman oder Hilman aus; der häufigste estnische Männervorname ist allerdings „Ilmar“.1
Ilmar A.: Meine Eltern waren Bauern.
David Boder: Aha, und wo haben die gelebt?
Ilmar A.: Die haben gelebt in [Ortsname; klingt wie „Tartaulag“], Gemeinde [Gemeindename, klingt wie „Saparau“ oder „Saparai“].
David Boder: Aha.
Ilmar A.: In [unverständlich].
David Boder: Also, erzählen Sie mir, was hat in der Universität passiert, wenn die Sowjets gekommen sind und was hat bei Ihnen zu Hause passiert?
Ilmar A.: Wenn die Sowjets sie sind zu uns kommen, dann war ich nicht Student, sondern war ich Schüler, war ich in Tartu, in der, alle waren zu Hause am ersten Morgen. Aber mein Vater hatte auch ein Fabrik und ein, einen Hof, ungefähr 35 Hektar. Aber bis 1941 im Mai passierte nicht besonderes, sondern am 14. Juni 1941 wurden ein Teil von meiner Verwandten verschleppt nach Sibirien. Deswegen, das waren auch Demokraten. Und...
David Boder: Was war das?
Ilmar A.: Die hatten demokratische Meinung.
David Boder: Ja, was heißt das, sie hatten „demokratische Meinung“?
Ilmar A.: Dass sie waren ehemalige, so, Angehörigen von der [Name der Organisation unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun ja , und? Weiter?
Ilmar A.: Und am 19., [verbessert sich] 1941, am vierzehnten Juni...
David Boder: [unverständlich; evtl. „Junitag“]
Ilmar A.: Ja, am 14. Junitag [unverständlich] wir haben so, so Bescheid bekommen, dass die Verschleppten konnten, wir waren im Wald.
David Boder: Wer war im Wald?
Ilmar A.: Meine Eltern und ich.
David Boder: Nun, weiter.
Ilmar A.: Und ..
David Boder: Sie waren im Wald. Wie haben Sie im Walde gelebt?
Ilmar A.: Wir waren im Walde. Die, wir versteckten uns im Wald.
David Boder: Nun ja, haben Sie dort ein Haus gehabt?
Ilmar A.: Nein, wir hatten kein Haus, sondern wir hatten ein...
David Boder: Zelt?
Ilmar A.: Zelt, oder so was. Und wir sind versteckt. Und...
David Boder: Wer war das alles zusammen, dieses Versteck?
Ilmar A.: Meine Eltern, meine Eltern, meine Schwester und ich.
David Boder: Ja. Wie viele, äh, wie viele Leute sind Sie in Ihrer Familie?
Ilmar A.: Sieben Leute.
David Boder: Aha. Und die ganze Familie hat sich im Walde versteckt?
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, wie lange haben Sie Sich im Walde versteckt?
Ilmar A.: Wir waren im Walde bloß, äh, vier, vier Wochen. Dann am 21. Juni 1941 ist, äh, sind aufgebrochen mit Richtung Deutschland, und...Und das war im Juli, die Deutschen sind schon zu uns gekommen. Und dann konnten wir wieder von der Walde raus. Dann im 1941, im Herbst besuchten wir meine Bruder Walter und am, das war im Jahre 1942, [unverständlich].
David Boder: Erzählen Sie das nochmal.
Ilmar A.: Was?
David Boder: Weiter. Haben die, die Deutschen irgendwie sich in die Schule hineingemischt?
Ilmar A.: Ja. Die Deutschen haben so [unverständlich] eingemischt, weil die, die konnten nicht unsere Organisation und so was haben. Früher wir hatten ein [unverständlich]-Organisation, das sich in die, die, für uns, äh, Haus-Organisation. Und wenn die wussten, die kommen zu uns, dann konnten wir die Organisation abschließen. Und ich war auch Mitglied dabei.
David Boder: Und das wurde abgeschlossen?
Ilmar A.: Das wurde abgeschlossen.
David Boder: Nun, und nachher? Wenn die Deutschen kamen?
Ilmar A.: Wenn die Deutschen kamen, dann konnten wir das nicht mehr öffnen. Und, das war im Jahre 1942, bin ich in die Universität dann, in die Dorpater Universität.
David Boder: Nun. Wollen Sie mir eins sagen; wenn die Russen gekommen sind, haben Sie gedacht, dass jetzt Estland Sowjet wird?
Ilmar A.: Ja. Die haben gesagt, dass Estland wird Sowjetunion.
David Boder: Und geht nach Russland rüber?
Ilmar A.: Ja. Das, so, offiziell die haben nicht gesagt.
David Boder: Aha.
Ilmar A.: Sondern es erschien so.
David Boder: Nun ja. Aber offiziell haben sie gesagt, Estland bleibt allein?
Ilmar A.: Nein, die haben nicht gesagt, weil wir hatten keine inter-, inter-, Verwaltung. Sondern wir hatten plötzlich, äh, sowjetische Verwaltung.
David Boder: Ja. Nun. Dann wenn die Deutschen gehen. Haben die Deutschen gesagt, dass Estland wird frei sein?
Ilmar A.: Nein, die Deutschen haben das auch nicht gesagt.
David Boder: Was haben die gesagt?
Ilmar A.: Dass die haben nicht gesagt, die hatten Besatzungstruppen drin. Und wir sollten auch als [unverständlich]-Besetzte Deutsche sein.
David Boder: Ach so. Die Deutschen, haben die Deutschen gesagt, dass sie Estland zu Deutschland nehmen?
Ilmar A.: Äh, vorläufig die haben nicht gesagt, sondern das war ein Besatzungsgebiet. Und die wollten uns, von uns alles Mögliche, äh, ausrotten.
David Boder: Ach so. Also weder die Deutschen noch die Russen haben Estland inkorporiert? Die Russen haben nicht eine Sowjetrepublik von Estland gemacht, haben sie?
Ilmar A.: Ja, die haben Sowjet, Estland –republik gemacht.
David Boder: Estland ist eine Sowjetrepublik geworden?
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Und wenn die Deutschen kamen, haben die Deutschen gesagt, dass sie nehmen Estland zu, oder was?
Ilmar A.: Nein, die haben nicht getan, sondern es war ein Besatzungsgebiet.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, Sie waren in einem besetzt, äh [korrigiert sich] Besatzungsgebiet. Und Sie mussten gewisse Arbeiten für die Deutschen leisten.
Ilmar A.: Die Deutschen leisten, ja.
David Boder: Haben die, die Deutschen welche Leute verhaftet, äh, hingerichtet und so weiter, oder verschleppt, wie die Russen es getan haben?
Ilmar A.: Ja. Die Deutschen haben das auch gemacht in höheren Maßen. Weil in 1942 besuche ich die Dorpater Universität und ich war damals sehr.
David Boder: Ja.
Ilmar A.: Die, die, die Deutschen haben, äh, unsere Professoren und unsere Studenten verfolgt. Und SB-Leute, halt, halt die Polizei hat mich immer und immer verfolgt. Und, äh, das war in 1943. In [undeutlich] wurde eine ganze Menge, fast 50 Prozent, äh, [undeutlich] von unsere Professoren und auch ein Teil von Studenten verhaftet.
David Boder: Aha. Und was hat man mit denen getan?
Ilmar A.: Die, die haben sie in, ins, äh, Zuchthaus gebracht.
David Boder: Und, Sie haben sie auch verhaftet?
Ilmar A.: Nein, ich meine und, deswegen, das waren unsere Studenten, und das, das eine Organisation oder eine...
David Boder: Ja.
Ilmar A.: . . . Gemeinschaftfamilie.
David Boder: Hat man Sie auch genommen? Sie persönlich?
Ilmar A.: Mich persönlich haben die nicht genommen. Aber ich wusste, dass die [undeutlich] wollten.
David Boder: Nun? Und dann, sagen Sie mir, äh, was hat weiter passiert?
Ilmar A.: Das war ´42, äh, dann bin ich auf Land hier gegangen zu meinen Eltern und wir hatten einen Hof auf dem Lande. Die Fabrik hatten wir nicht mehr und die Russen haben die Fabrik [unverständliches Verb, endet auf „ –tiert“].
David Boder: Was für eine Fabrik war das?
Ilmar A.: Das war Back-Fabrik.
David Boder: Nun, haben die Deutschen die Fabrik zurückgegeben?
Ilmar A.: Nein. Die Deutschen haben das auch nicht zurückgeben, sondern sie haben alles, äh, alle Sachen, alle Maschinen und, äh, [unverständlich]
David Boder: [Unverständlich]?
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, weiter. Wollten Sie sagen, dass die Deutschen Ihre Maschinen mitgenommen haben, oder sie haben die Maschinen sozusagen arbeiten gelassen für die Deutschen?
Ilmar A.: Sie haben zuerst arbeiten gelassen für die Deutschen und zuletzt, wenn sie sonst nichts mehr her-kommen, dann haben die Maschinen zurückgebracht,...
David Boder: . . . evakuiert?
Ilmar A.: . . . evakuiert nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Ja. Und Sie waren in der Universität?
Ilmar A.: Äh, ich war, äh, im Winter war ich in der Universität.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann was hat Ihnen weiter passiert? Ihnen und Ihrer Familie?
Ilmar A.: Dann, äh, ich war, im Sommer war ich auf dem Lande. Und im Herbst bin ich nach Tartu wieder zurückgekehrt. Und ich konnte studieren bis 1944, Februar.
David Boder: Und dann?
Ilmar A.: Dann s/wollte ich wieder aufs Lande gehen, weil die sonst, ich, wieder [undeutlich, evtl. „näher und näher“] kommen,
David Boder: [undeutliches Verb]?
Ilmar A.: Ja, [undeutlich; wiederholt Boder]. Und unsere Universität sollte seine Türe abschließen. [Unverständlich], ich war auf dem Lande, was die Deutschen haben wieder eine Verhaftung gemacht, von den Professoren und, äh, von den, auch ein Teil von den Studenten.
David Boder: Und was haben sie gesagt, warum haben sie die Leute verhaftet?
Ilmar A.: Deswegen haben die verhaftet, dass die hatten Zweifel auf uns, dass wir haben Verbindungen mit Finnland und mit Schweden. Und wir haben auch geholfen, das ist die Wahrheit, dass wir haben geholfen die Leute nach Finnland und nach Schweden flüchten.
David Boder: Aha. Aber Finnland hat ja mit den Deutschen gekämpft, die Finnland war ja auf der deutschen Seite?
Ilmar A.: Ja, die Finnland war auf deutsche Seite, die sollte auf deutsche Seite sein. Deswegen dass Russland wollte Finnland besetzen.
David Boder: Aber warum haben dann die Deutschen Angst gehabt, dass Sie nach Finnland gehen?
Ilmar A.: Deswegen wollten sie uns nicht nach Finnland schicken, weil wir, die [betont] Leute, das wollten nach Finnland flüchten gehen, haben gesagt [unverständlich], die waren nicht gerichtet als Kommunisten auch nicht gerichtet als Nazisten oder Faschisten. Die waren, äh, so...
David Boder: Unparteiisch?
Ilmar A.: Unparteiisch, freie Demokraten.
David Boder: Und, weiter?
Ilmar A.: Und ein Teil von uns ist dann nach Finnland und nach Schweden geflüchtet. Jetzt haben wir in Schweden 35.000 Personen, haben wir dort Untergrund-Personen und auch meistens intelligent.
David Boder: Ja. Und, wie leben die dort in Schweden? Leben die auch so wie hier, wie die, die...
Ilmar A.: Die, die leben nicht in Schweden, wie die [unklar], sondern die müssen dort arbeiten. Und die haben schon gelernt schwedische Sprache. Und arbeiten irgendwo in der Handwerk und haben sich ganz einfach Arbeiten. Aber, so, Facharbeit haben sie nicht gekriegt, weil sind sie Professoren, oder die Intelligenz hat nicht gekriegt ein entsprechende Arbeit, sondern müssen..
David Boder: Physisch arbeiten?
Ilmar A.: Physische Arbeit machen, leisten.
David Boder: Und die UNRRA hilft dort, oder, äh,?
Ilmar A.: Das habe ich keine Ahnung, aber glaube ich, dass ist UNRRA ist nicht dort, sondern..
David Boder: Sie sind einfach dort...
Ilmar A.: einfach
David Boder: . . . wie Migranten, wie Emigranten?
Ilmar A.: wie Emigranten, als Emigranten dort.
David Boder: Nun, weiter, was hat Ihnen?
Ilmar A.: Hier konnte ich immer mehr [undeutlich] von, bis September 1944. Dann sollte ich von meinem Haus wegkommen, sollte mein Haus ichverlassen.
David Boder: Warum?
Ilmar A.: Deswegen weil die Front ist näherge-, näherkommen und ich wollte nach Schweden flüchten. Aber meine Eltern sind zurückgeblieben. Und die konnten nicht mitkommen, deswegen weil sie waren, äh, alt. Gesundheit war nicht mehr in Ordnung. Das war am 20. September 1944, wollte ich von [Ortsname; klingt wie „Atrau?] wegfahren nach Schweden. Wir hatten ein Boot und wollten über die See nach Schweden flüchten. Wir waren schon unterwegs so ein Tag, aber in der Nacht wir hatten Unglück und die Deutschen haben uns geschnappt.
David Boder: Wo war das?
Ilmar A.: Das war auf der See.
David Boder: Und was sind Sie, bei, bei Boot gegangen?
Ilmar A.: Ja, bei Boot.
David Boder: Was für ein Boot?
Ilmar A.: Das war ganz einfach ein kleines, kleines Boot.
David Boder: Motorboot?
Ilmar A.: Nein, [unverständlich]. Ja, es war ein Motorboot.
David Boder: Und wo wollten Sie hinübergehen?
Ilmar A.: Wir wollten nach Schweden übergehen.
David Boder: Konnte man auf solch einem Boot nach Schweden rüberfahren?
Ilmar A.: Nein, sie dürfen nicht rüberfahren.
David Boder: Ja, aber ich meine, kann solch ein Boot nach Schweden rüberfahren?
Ilmar A.: Ja, wir dachten schon, dass wir können zu fahren, das war, äh, die letzte Möglichkeit.
David Boder: Wie viel Leute waren im Boot?
Ilmar A.: Das war sechs Leute im Boot.
David Boder: Aha, und das hat einen Motor gehabt?
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Und haben Sie genug Gasolin gehabt, rüberzuholen [sic!]?
Ilmar A.: Ja, wir haben nicht so viel Gasolin gehabt, aber wir hatten, äh, auch Ruder dabei.
David Boder: Aha.
Ilmar A.: Ja, und zuletzt wir vielleicht hätten ge-, gerudert.
David Boder: Nun. Und wo haben Sie die Deutschen gefangen?
Ilmar A.: Die Deutschen ungefähr in der Mitte auf der See haben uns geschnappt.
David Boder: Wie viel Tage waren Sie schon weg vom, vom Ufer?
Ilmar A.: Ich war ungefähr einen Tag weg.
David Boder: Aha. Nun das war doch nicht in der Mitte, man kann ja nicht...
Ilmar A.: [Unverständlich] ein Tag, in zwei Tagen bist Du auch herüber.
David Boder: [erstaunt] Nach Schweden?
Ilmar A.: Ja, nach Schweden.Von Estland nach Schweden sind es mehrere hundert Kilometer! Meint er vielleicht Finnland?1
David Boder: Achja, und weiter.
Ilmar A.: Und die haben uns nach Deutschland gebracht.
David Boder: Und was hat dann passiert?
Ilmar A.: Das war im Lager und ich bin der Sohn eines Bauern. Dann ich habe gesagt, dass ich kann irgendwo auf dem Lande arbeiten. Dann ich habe jetzt gemeint, dann kann ich vielleicht am besten so am Leben bleiben. Weil die Verpflegung war sehr schlecht.
David Boder: In was für einem Lager waren Sie?
Ilmar A.: Das war in [Gotenhafen?].
David Boder: [unverständlich; evtl. „ - am Hafen“?]. Wie viel Leute waren in diesem Lager im Allgemeinen? War das ein großes Konzentrationslager?
Ilmar A.: Das ist, das war nicht Konzentrationslager, sondern das war ein Durchgangslager oder so was und der Zahl der Leute kann ich nicht sagen.
David Boder: So ungefähr, wie viel schätzen Sie?
Ilmar A.: Die waren 1000 dort.
David Boder: 1000.
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie hat, haben sich die Deutschen gegen Ihnen persönlich benommen?
Ilmar A.: Zuerst waren sie [unverständlich], aber zuletzt sie haben gesagt, „Ja, Sie können dort auf die Arbeit gehen und können Sie auch dann weggehen“, sie waren dort bloß drei Tage. Ich habe erzählt, dass ich bin Sohn des Bauers und ich kann auf dem Lande irgendwo arbeiten.
David Boder: Sie waren im Lager bloß drei Tage?
Ilmar A.: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Nun, weiter.
Ilmar A.: Dann bin ich gegangen nach...
David Boder: Haben Sie die Deutschen nach irgendwelcher Zeit geschlagen?
Ilmar A.: Nein, mich persönlich geschlagen haben sie nicht.
David Boder: Warum nicht? Haben die jemand anders geschlagen?
Ilmar A.: Das habe ich gesehen, aber mich haben sie nicht, nicht.
Ilmar A.: Und wer waren die Leute, die sie geschlagen haben?
Ilmar A.: Das kann ich nicht sagen. Ich weiß nicht, was für Nationalität oder so was haben, das waren, äh, von vielen Nationalitäten, auch Letten, Litauer, Polen, und alle mögliche.
David Boder: Nun, weiter. Sind Sie aufs Land gegangen?
Ilmar A.: Und ich war auf dem Lande und ich arbeitete dort bis, äh, 5. Mai 1945.
David Boder: Was hat dann passiert? (Einen Moment.) [Boder spricht mit jemand im Hintergrund?]. Wie hat sich der Bauer gegen Ihnen benommen? Hat er Ihnen genug zu essen gegeben?
Ilmar A.: Genug Essen hat er nicht gegeben, sondern ich habe extra gegessen.
David Boder: Was heißt „extra gegessen“?
Ilmar A.: Extra gegessen im, in einem Zimmer und der Bauer hat gegessen im Speisesaal.
David Boder: Und was haben sie Ihnen, und haben sie Ihnen etwas bezahlt?
Ilmar A.: Dort bezahlt haben sie uns 23 Mark pro Monat.
David Boder: Und wer war mit Ihnen?
Ilmar A.: Wie bitte?
David Boder: Sie sagen „uns“, wer war denn noch mit Ihnen?
Ilmar A.: Na, ich meine das, äh,
David Boder: Im Allgemeinen?
Ilmar A.: im allgemeinen, [undeutlich].
David Boder: 23 Mark pro Monat. Und was konnte man für 23 Mark kaufen?
Ilmar A.: Für das Geld konnte man nichts kaufen.
David Boder: Haben Sie eine Lebensmittelkarte gehabt?
Ilmar A.: Nein. Ich habe nicht gehabt, sondern Bauer hat mir gegeben. Zu Essen gegeben.
David Boder: Zu Essen gegeben. Wie hat der Bauer, wie hat der Bauer sich benommen? War er anständig? War er freundlich?
Ilmar A.: Zuerst war er nicht freundlich, aber zuletzt ich habe gut gearbeitet, weil ich bin doch junger Mann und der Bauer war ganz anständig.
David Boder: Nun. Und was hat im 5. Mai, sagten Sie ja, den 5. März [sic], was ist dann passiert? Was war das?
Ilmar A.: Dann sind die Amerikanische Besatzungstruppe gekommen und wir sind gefreit von Deutschen, wir konnten von Amerikaner verpflegt werden.
David Boder: Wo war das? War das im...?
Ilmar A.: Das war in Oberlungwitz, das war...
David Boder: Ist das in der Amerikanischen Zone?
Ilmar A.: Nein, das ist nicht jetzt in Amerikanische Zone, sondern jetzt ist die Russische Zone.
David Boder: Es ist die Russische Zone?
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Und, sind Sie von der Zone nach hier gekommen, nach München?
Ilmar A.: Ich bin von der Zone so ge-, geflüchtet wieder.
David Boder: Warum?
Ilmar A.: Deswegen weil ich habe gehört, dass die Russen kommen hin. Und ich hatte sowieso Angst, weil ich flüchte schon 1944 vor den Russen und ich weiß, was das bedeutet, das war
David Boder: [unterbricht] In `44 sind Sie doch nicht von den Russen geflohen? `44 sind Sie von den Deutschen geflohen.
Ilmar A.: Von den Deutschen und auch hier von den Russen.
David Boder: Ach dass die Russen kommen, ja.
Ilmar A.: Die Russen sind gekommen und ich weiß, was es bedeutet, eine russische Besatzung deswegen, dass, äh, im 1941 am 14. Juli, man wurde, wurde verschleppt 60.000 Männern und Frauen nach Sibirien. 60.000 von uns
David Boder: Sechzehn ?
Ilmar A.: Sechzig.
David Boder: Sechzigtausend.
Ilmar A.: Ja. Das bedeutet, äh, ein, äh, sieben Prozent ..
David Boder: Ja, von den ganzen
Ilmar A.: von den ganzen Bevölkerung.
David Boder: Nun? [Kurze Pause in der Aufnahme] Was hat dort passiert?
Ilmar A.: Hier habe ich gelebt und ich wollte wieder hier weiterstudieren und ich habe gebeten, Möglichkeit zu geben, hier in Deutschland irgendwo weiterstudieren. Jetzt habe ich gehört, dass
David Boder: Ja?
Ilmar A.: habe ich gehört, dass hier in München wird, gründet eine UNRRA-Universität, das ist eine internationale Universität, wo studieren 19, 12...
David Boder: Aha. Und was studieren Sie hier?
Ilmar A.: Ich studiere Bauwesen.
David Boder: Was? Bauwesen?
Ilmar A.: Bauwesen.
David Boder: Architektur?
Ilmar A.: Archi-, nein, nicht Archi-, sondern Fachrichtung Bauwesen.
David Boder: Nun ja, Häuser zu bauen?
Ilmar A.: Häuser Tief- und Hochbau.
David Boder: Was heißt Tiefbau?
Ilmar A.: Dass, auch Wasserbau, äh, und Kanal, Kanäle, und [unverständlich] und so weiter.
David Boder: Aha, und wie lange wird das nehmen?
Ilmar A.: Hier in Deutschland wird es nehmen 3 Jahre. Wir haben Tri-Semester, wir haben drei Semester im Jahr.
David Boder: Ja. Und in welcher Sprache wird es unterrichtet?
Ilmar A.: Unterrichtet wird auf der deutschen Sprache.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mal. Und wo denken Sie von hier zu gehen? Hören Sie von Ihren Eltern? Was hat Ihren Eltern passiert?
Ilmar A.: Ich habe nicht von meinen Eltern gehört, deswegen weil wir haben keine Verbindung. Meiner Meinung nach sind meine Eltern schon verschleppt worden nach Sibirien. Das ist wahrscheinlich.
David Boder: Und was tun die Leute, wenn sie nach Sibirien verschleppt werden?
Ilmar A.: Die sind, äh, Facharbeiter.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mir, wie und, äh...
Ilmar A.: . . . einen Onkel in Amerika haben, aber ich weiß kein Anschrift, ich weiß keine Adresse.
David Boder: Nun, Herr Ilman, ich möchte noch so vieles von Ihnen hören, aber ich habe mir vorgenommen, dass ich von allen eine halbe Stunde, mit allen eine halbe Stunde spreche. Wir sind schon eine halbe Stunde zusammen [die vorliegende Aufnahme ist noch keine 27 Minuten gelaufen, was die abrupten Themenwechsel erklären könnte].
Ilmar A.: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, also wollen Sie mir jetzt den nächsten Herren hereinschicken?
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Ilmar A., he doesn’t give his full name, 23 years old, Estonian student of the UNRRA University in Munich, September the 24th, 1946, Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: This is reproduction 9-152-A, the continuation of Spool 152 will be then on 9-152-B, split up for convenience. This is the spool re-duplicated for the U.S. Public Health Service. November 11, 1949.